number one pretty straightforward I hope
this X cubed we take it first does it
become X to the 4 on 4 subs up in index
up divine minus 3 does that x minus 3 X
and then the constant of integration is
hanging around so we're happy with a
cool now be who put BAE up okay any
thank you now who had the answer looking
like that
exactly anyone one just one other okay
interesting if you did it another way or
let me ask is who expanded this thing a
few more hands but still not everyone's
okay in I'm interested if you'd rather
did that or came up with this out are
let's have a think about how this came
about because this is the most efficient
way I can tell by the way it's written
okay when we have a guard this yes we
could expand but if I can avoid it I
will because expanding is a long process
and then I have to begin to grow in
training so it's like two things that I
have to do I'd rather do just one I can
use the rule we've developed a couple
lessons ago which is the reverse chain
rule here's a function right and you're
applying a different function to that
okay so I'm going to try it undo reverse
chain rule let's have a go at how he did
it
you've got this X on three plus two and
the power used to be two when we're
doing reverse trainer what happens to I
should say index the index goes to plus
one so it's now it's now a three okay
but then the next step is just like with
this X to the four on for you you divide
by the new power okay so then we get a
three now at this point here I have
taken care of the outside the squared
bit but I haven't taken care of the
inside the inside the chain function
chain rule rather does the inside and
the outside reverse chain rule also has
to do the inside and the outside
what is the inside derivative in this
case it's
one over three right so this inside
derivative 1 over 3 what do I do with it
I divide by that now this is actually
sneaky a few of us have sort of been
caught up because when you integrate
you're gonna get fractions these kind of
happen all the time ok and I've been
admittedly mean to you by giving you a
function and integrand
that will land you with fractions on
fractions if you're dividing this thing
by a third then the 1/3 appears in the
denominator because the denominator is
the thing doing division right so you
can see here once I had my ad my
constant of integration which is always
there you can see how we get from here
to the answer that Eddy's written are
you happy with that ok
you can of course go ahead and expand
all this provided you did expansion
correctly you'll still end up with this
but I look different because presumably
you also be an expanded form this is um
this is factorize ok all right last one
having a look at this answer here was
that you know e that was your answer ok
um who's got that answer a few okay just
to quickly get how he did that there's
really one key thing you need to do with
this before you just proceed as usual we
haven't been given the integrand in a
nice form to work with what should we do
with it ok so we can take this part of
the numerator divide through separate it
out 4x squared divided by X 2 gives us
4x so I the integrand integral sign is
still decks I haven't done it yet X
divided by X I can deal with that part
which is just 1 and now that I've
written in a much neater form hopefully
it's now clear to you where this came
from the index has gone up
he's divided by that new index the 4
divided by the 2 leaves him with 2 and
then off he goes from there so thumbs up
are you happy ok well done ok well done
but we really need to work enough
fluency there that took us wait you know
okay can I ask you to rule that off and
make a new heading which is integrating
exponential functions
though you could have been right I mean
it was a good guess it's a good guess
okay now you will recall we keep on
saying it to try and drill it into your
head everything we know about
integration at least so far everything
we know about it we know from
differentiation we know how to
differentiate exponential functions in
fact they're delightfully easy to
differentiate because if I gave you a
function like say this you could say
it's derivative because you don't even
you almost have to do nothing what is
the beauty of this guy what's it's it's
e to the X that's kind of a special
thing about this specific exponential
function that when you differentiate it
you just get back itself okay so since
we have a statement about
differentiation here right we can make
an equivalent or parallel statement
about integration yeah what if I asked
you to integrate e to the X with respect
to X what would you expect yeah yeah you
would you'd go back where you came from
with one subtle difference which is that
constant of integration because e to the
X plus 1 e to the X minus 500 they would
all still differentiate and land us here
okay ah can you say that again loudest
around e to the X I'm just gonna write
this down so I have it in my head e to
the X on ax plus 1 okay now I want to
make this stop it's because it was
mentioned it's a good one
this is an error which crops up all the
time if this is in fact not the integral
but it's it comes up frequent enough
that's worth mentioning where's this
come from by the way this is not come
from nowhere why might we think like why
are we are we in the habit of like
dividing what is it
we've been doing that a lot haven't we
right but why is that what kinds what
family of functions have we been dealing
is so far they're not Exponential's what
would you call in all of these that's
with a P mm-hmm
we end up with sorry bad yeah I badly
phrase the question we end up with a
premium but what we were taking was a
polynomial the primitive ends up being a
polynomial - these are not polynomials
they're Exponential's so they're behave
quite differently we don't and you might
have you know another common error is
that it's like increase the index by one
and then divide by that but this is a
whole different kettle of fish okay X is
not in the base at all it's in the index
okay let's see if we can push on this
using you know this reverse chain rule
stuff didn't just apply to polynomials
it also applied to Exponential's so just
to get your brain back in gear if I
asked you and I'm gonna ask you to do
this right now if I ask you to
differentiate say this okay so you're
doing again inside and outside it's just
the inside is up there in the index so
it's derivative as said is 3 ok I'm
differentiated that part and now I do
the outside it's just an e ^ it's an
expecially you just hand back that
exponential now because on this line
I've differentially hit it right so is
there any posse not at this point we
don't know we didn't need that for
derivatives but now when I integrate
with a different story right so now
let's just take that same function let's
try integrating we know integrating
undoes everything that differentiation
does here I multiplied by the inside
derivative what do you think I should do
here to undo that I should divide
divisions the opposite of multiplication
so I'm dividing by what 3 so I'll just
write the third at the front that's me
dividing by 3 and then I've got to deal
with this what happens to that
exponential it just comes back to being
itself right so it's e to the 3x and now
because I'm integrating costs of
integration okay and again I implore you
a lot of you asking me like I've I got
it right okay it's not just worth it so
you don't have to wait for a teacher to
come around but it's worth it for you to
flex your differentiation muscles
just have a look at this and say if I
differentiate this am I going to bless
you
am I going to land back at the integrand
I came from what's gonna happen yeah
that three just like here it's gonna
come out the front three the one-third e
to the three X is still there what
happens to the [ __ ] it's gone I can
disregard it cuz it's constant and there
thankfully is what I was hoping for this
is just me proving to myself oh yeah I
did get it right because this is what I
was supposed to do um integrate okay